[Music]
we live in a world that is filled with
so much noise a 2018 Deloitte study so
the average American picks up their
phone 52 times a day now you may be
thinking and doing the math that's twice
an hour that's not so bad
but when you'd factor in the time that
you're spending sleeping eating driving
a car having sex things you should all
be doing without a phone in your hand
it's really more like once every 10
minutes
when is the last time you voluntarily
turned off your phone for 24 hours 48
hours I would say for the device in your
pocket all the alerts the dings the
bings the emails is keeping you from
living your best life and I'm not
talking about Kardashian best life I'm
talking about a life that is aligned
intentionally with your values and your
desires eight years ago I was not living
my best life I was living a good life
but it was not my best life I was
leading two teams of 45 people creating
450 pieces of editorial content each
month for 2 million Americans you might
say I was contributing to the content
problem
I was working 12 to 15 hour days trying
to manage those 45 direct reports and
every morning I would get up at 7 a.m.
the first thing I would do was check my
phone
I would then commute up to the city for
an hour have a full day commute back
down have dinner get back on my laptops
or typing away emails and every night
before I went to bed whether it was at
1:30 to 2:30 3:00 the last thing I did
every night was check my phone one last
time to see if there was an email that I
missed
that same year on a Saturday in October
I had a Friday just like the Friday that
I add a that I told you about I remember
that I was tired but I still wanted to
make that drive from the city of to the
city to get a drink with my friend for
her birthday I remember driving to the
city I remember it was a cold San
Francisco night
pretty much every night in San Francisco
was cold
I remember huddling under the heat lamp
trying to get warm
I remember feeling tired and then I
started to feel odd I started to feel
really weird and I remember I walked
over to the bar to get a glass of water
hoping that that glass of water would
somehow make me feel better and the next
thing I knew I was on the floor of the
bar I had fainted so this is a part of
this story for most people say this was
the turning point this is the moment
that I realized that my life really
needed to change that is not how this
story goes the next day I went to the
doctor and she said you are a very
normal healthy 26 year old except that
you were severely dehydrated and
exhausted so I went and I fixed those
two things i rehydrated myself I got a
little bit more sleep and I went right
back to my life my overworked exhausted
tech addicted life those next eight
years are really intense we nearly ran
out of money twice that company I was
telling you about we raised more money
we sold that company to a much bigger
company taking our 250 person
organization and trying to integrate it
into this 250,000 person organization I
left that company I ended a really
important relationship but that year
that first dear that I was telling you
about I began a practice that has
transformed the way I live that year I
began the practice of retreating from my
life in order to move forward in my life
with greater intention and
purpose every three months right after
work on Friday I drive up into the
California hills into that beautiful
golden place I go to my favorite retreat
center silence day I get out of my car
and let the beauty and the silence begin
to fill my soul but the thing that I do
is I take out my phone and I turn it off
for the next 36 hours until Sunday
afternoon this practice has grounded me
through the storms of life it has
created space for me to simply be space
to reflect on my life and it's given my
brain 36 hours to detached from my
technology addiction
helping my brain reset just once so I
want to invite you all to join me in
retreating from your life to move
forward maybe you are feeling like I did
desperate overworked maybe for you it's
being a parent that daily grind
maybe it's laundry chores dishes repeat
maybe it's the weight of figuring out
who you want to be right now and who you
want to be in the future now I know some
of you are thinking Tiffany this is
crazy I can't take off 36 hours for my
life I know the extroverts out there are
thinking I can't be quiet for two hours
much less 36 hours I know the parents
are thinking I cannot abandon my
co-parent for the entire weekend they
will kill me when I get back so I have a
challenge for you I'm calling it the
coffee top coffee shop challenge I
invite you to take a small tech detox of
just two hours this weekend this
Saturday or Sunday go to a coffee shop
and turn off your phone for two hours
and during that time you can do the
three things that I do whenever I go on
my retreats first I turn off my phone
you'll have already done that to I begin
to reflect on the last three
not your whole life just the last three
months what worked what didn't what
really sucked what do you want to do
differently and then lastly I pull out
the list of things I would love to do
with my life and I choose one thing to
do in the next three months if you don't
have that list this weekend is a perfect
time to make that list we live in a
world that is filled with so much noise
resist the urge to consume more
information and do more instead turn
inwards my senior year at Stanford I
remember reading this line that has
stuck with me to this day
Richard foster in the celebration of
discipline said the desperate need in
our world today is not for more gifted
or intelligent people but for deep
people I'm going to say it again
the desperate need in our world today is
not for more gifted people or
intelligent people but deep people
friends you are some of the most gifted
and intelligent people I know and your
life challenge will be to figure out
what is your gift to the world but
before you lead others before you change
lives change organizations and change
the world I want to invite you all to
begin by changing yourself that starts
by turning off your phone and turning
inwards
[Applause]
[Music]